Margate was among 101 towns from across
England selected to bid for funding from
the government's Towns Fund Initiative. This
is a once-in-a-generation opportunity to invest
in local projects, drive growth and improve
the environment for the benefit of the whole
community. The Town Deal comes at an important
and exciting time in Margate's history. The town
has faced its challenges over the last 50 years
and now is the time to come together to make sure
it has a thriving economy 365 days a year. At the
heart of the Town Deal is the town investment plan
which sets out a long-term vision and strategy for
Margate, the investment plan makes the case for a
29 million pound investment supporting projects
themed around four interlinking interventions.
These build on what makes Margate so special and
deliver change that will benefit local people
and visitors for years to come. Margate's growing
creative and cultural economy is an opportunity
not to be missed the first intervention is
therefore a nine million pound investment in
scaling Margate's creative production and skills.
It will establish a creative land trust to support
projects stretching from the High Street to
the Theatre Royal, building spaces for creative
production and education. Potential locations
include the former Marks and Spencers, Primark and
other key sites within the High Street. Investment
will bring life back to the town centre linking
the coast to the historic Hawley Square and
establishing a creative economic hub driving jobs,
skills, education and engagement. In its heyday
Margate was known as a place for well-being and
tourism. The second intervention is a 6.5 million
pound investment in coastal well-being to support
projects across Margate's coastline creating
new and surprising experiences for visitors.
Establishing better links between the town
centre Northdown Road and the coastline
will deliver an improved network of connections
and encourage people to explore beyond the
seafront. The third intervention focuses on public
realm and connections with a 4.5 million pound
targeted investment in the town centre, coastline
and residential areas making it easier to get
around and improving visitor amenities. This will
better connect Northdown Road to the town centre
and create attractive public spaces as well as
enhancing cycling and walking infrastructure.
Margate's past has a role to play in its future.
The fourth intervention is therefore a nine
million pound investment in well-loved heritage
assets and will help secure a sustainable future
for the Dreamland cinema complex and the Winter
Gardens which benefits the wider town. It will
create new enterprise and cultural spaces for
both visitors and the community. It will also
support the development of feasibility plans for
the future of important landmarks including the
Arlington Arcade the old Town Hall and the lido.
The town investment plan has now been submitted
to the Ministry of Housing Communities and Local
Government. Thank you to everyone who took the
time to get involved and share their views. We're
currently waiting to hear back from the government
and in the meantime the Town Deal board and
project team continue to work in partnership with
stakeholders local businesses and the community.
You can read the town investment plan in full
keep up to date with how the deal progresses and
sign up to receive news at margatetowndeal.co.uk